there's a new and unique dining
experience inside the planet 13
entertainment complex here in vegas
let's head to tressay eatery and spirits
[Music]
we're at tracee eatery and spirits
located at the plant 13
entertainment complex right up the strip
tracee is a really a mexican-american
restaurant
we specialize in you know a vast amount
of food dishes
we have everything from you know tacos
and enchiladas
to really like lamb chops and raviolis
and
even even some southern dishes and i
think really where we where we finish
off is
our really specialty cocktails um
they're fabulous here and uh
we've become a favorite amongst locals
and tourists
we want to make you feel like you're in
a green house basically you look up you
see the blue skies
you look out to the side looks like
you're you're viewing the las vegas
strip
and we really wanted to create you know
a really high-end restaurant
that you could see and feel comfortable
enjoying you know whether it's you know
in the morning for breakfast or
at night for dinner we really try to
create environment in our bar area where
you can get really high specialty
cocktails really quality food
and be able to watch the game and
actually spend hours here manny you are
the chef here after
talking to david i've got the munchies
all right i'm ready to eat so let's talk
about these dishes
sure definitely so we have a little bit
for everybody um so right here we have a
little southern chicken and waffles uh
our homemade grabbing my fork definitely
go right ahead go right ahead
so we have a ricotta cheese ravioli with
the white wine sauce a little bit of
fresh
seasonal vegetables um you know
something light you know not too heavy
maybe lunch brunch you know
if you're feeling that mood so we also
go
down to our shrimp and grits our
homemade uh lobster cognac sauce
creamy grits blackened shrimp you know
and a little bit of
cilantro on top just has a garnish a
little vibrant colors so
our fajitas you know obviously grilled
and cooked to order
slice it very thin that way you can
enjoy you know you could build your own
taco if you will
now i heard this is a show our server
does a little bit of tequila around it
hits it with the fire and it's just a
little show just a little wow factor for
the guests to enjoy
do it big in vegas now we have some
beautiful cocktails here
yes and you guys do specialize in that
here as well well definitely so we have
a great variety of cocktails you know we
have happy hour you know a regular menu
you know our general manager category
she's a great mixologist as well
which which cocktail pairs well with the
ravioli because i want to take
well you could really go with anything
you know what i mean obviously the the
fajita of mexico's margarita can't go
wrong
no nice colorful like you set out
flavorful as well you know we uh
dehydrate our own our own fruits for the
cocktails
so i should just do it any mini mining
well yeah go right ahead go right there
all right i'm going for this this one's
the cactus the cactus glass
[Music]
is that like hibiscus what is that no
it's this one's actually a
prickly pear puree and the salt around
okay it's great i am i am sold i am
convinced i'm going to be here
for breakfast lunch and dinner tressay
eatery and spirits inside the planet 13
entertainment complex
visit tuesdaylasvegas.com for more
information and join them for happy hour
from 3 p.m to 6 p.m
monday through friday